hey what is up guys I'm could be HD here
and welcome to another video I'm sure
you've already been aware that the smart
speaker market has been heating up a lot
over the past couple months and year and
a half so we got Google assistant in the
form of Google home in that smart
speaker and we got series smart
assistant in a home pod but today we
have a bit of an exclusive for you guys
our first look at samsung smart
assistant in the form of a Bixby home
the Bixby smart speaker so we're gonna
give it a shot we already know I mean
Samsung's been doing great with hardware
especially on their phones we kind of
just give them that they're top-notch
but it's the software where we start to
have some questions you know Bixby you
probably saw that virtual assistant
comparison video didn't do so hot but
it's been a couple months there's been
some updates so let's give this another
shot so the box is pretty simple pretty
inviting I feel like in this day and age
if you're gonna be putting a smart
speaker in someone's house you kind of
have to make it inviting to not have
them freak out about it
but if we take it out it looks pretty
good we got some some Bixby blue these
blue accents but uh it's nice and dense
it's weighted it's pretty clean honestly
it looks like a pretty good smart
speaker there's are these buttons at the
top and they're blue I guess there's no
screen kind of like Google assistant or
home pod they all have that little
screen at the top but you don't really
use that when you're across the room so
that's not I'm not taking points off for
that so we've got to get past this
beautiful hardware and see if if Bixby
is all about it because that's what
makes or breaks a smart speaker if the
assistant actually does its job so uh
hey Bixby what's your name my name is
Bigsby okay so I mean that's I said the
name in the question but that's cool it
got it all right hey Bixby what's the
weather the weather refers to day-to-day
temperature and precipitation activity
okay technically correct but I was more
looking for like the weather here right
now hey Bixby what's the weather in New
York City right now it is currently 50
degrees in cloudy in New York City okay
so you've got to be a little more
specific but it gets it right so that's
that's the simple default question of
the weather so basically we know there's
a long list of things that can probably
do like set a timer
I look up information on Google we kind
of wanted to be able to do also the more
novel things like answering more random
questions Google uses the knowledge
graph so hey Bixby how far away is the
moon far far away yeah I think most
would have most would have given an
answer in like miles/hour kilometers or
something but you're not wrong Bixby
you're not wrong I don't know most of
them can tell jokes so uh hey Bixby tell
me a joke knock knock who's there aren't
you glad I didn't say banana
haha you kind of forgot half of that
they don't all have to have good jokes
that's that's not a big deal that that's
a missing feature um okay so you know
that's Siri like what they think of
Google and vice versa hey Bixby what do
you think of Siri dad
okay at least hey the mute switch is
very responsive I think it's a play
button it's still gone okay
maybe something a little less triggering
for you Bixby uh hey Bixby just do a
trick okay pick a number between one and
two okay is your number one no actually
okay now that's started going out ho for
a second but I think Bixby home can
still redeem itself as a legitimate
smart speaker cuz it's still it's able
to answer questions right so I have a
press release from Samsung here says
they've interestingly built in a
fail-safe to make sure it definitely
answers complex questions which I mean
that's what it comes down to we're
asking a jokes and stuff but it can
still save itself so hey Bixby what's 37
times the square root of 94 that's a
tough one okay Google what is 37 times
the square root of 94 that's that's
cheating
fifty eight point seven two eight that's
that's cheating no it's not alright
maybe uh maybe we asked a little too
much of it maybe just a phone call maybe
that's that's the simple hey Bixby call
Mandy okay playin call me maybe by Carly
Rae Jepsen stop no stop all right
this is something home pod can do this
is something Google assistant can do
hey Bixby turn the studio light blue
okay playing blue by Eiffel 65 sorry for
getting both of those songs stuck in
your head today okay I at this point I'm
trying to I'm trying to figure out if
it's really a smart speaker like if
there's if there's anything this does
better than home pod or Google assistant
that would be great I think the one
thing Samsung mentioned is it has a
removable cable which you know that's
good
it's kind of hard actually okay that's
not that was mmm they thought about it
they tried they tried that's what it
comes down to Samsung tried they they
wanted to make it a little more portable
than Google home and home pod so if you
manage to remove the speaker correctly
it has built-in battery and they push
the limits with this battery it's gonna
be sitting around on a countertop for a
lot so they said they put in a sixty
thousand milliamp hour battery which is
pretty massive pushing the limits for a
small form-factor like this so ideally
it should be able to last up to Oh
[Music]
okay this is a hopefully you guys by now
know this April Fool's Day this is your
yearly reminder not to take anything you
read or watch too seriously I mean if
they made a smart speaker and totally
better than this right for sure
anyway catch you guys the next one peace
you